Chris Gore, Owner of Film Threat: …To be
original in the same way that the first one,
what people liked about that,
flip that defy expectations.
Film Courage: I’ll go back several decades
but Staying Alive and Saturday Night Fever
(and I know I'm really dating myself here)
but both fantastic films. Staying Alive to me
um I'm sorry yeah Staying Alive was a little
bit better in my sense more interesting than
Saturday Night Fever just because I enjoyed John
Travolta's journey, staying in this crummy Hotel,
he's this hungry dancer, he meets Finola
Hughes who's got this upper hand and can
help him but there are strings attached.
It's just a fantastic cast of characters
and to me I thought that the storytelling was
was richer, but again that's going back several
years it's not a franchise. I understand that
some of the viewers may not know that movie
but I thought that the storytelling was way
better but I yeah. Do you remember the movie?
Chris Gore: Yeah, I remember it
and uh I wish I could forget it.